he has done it again another highlight reel save
he's got real interesting there they sure did head
fake Maran there's a shot oh what a glove save
zaka wondering what he needs to do to beat the
Blue Jackets net minder that puck is labeled on
its way to the top half of the net Coyle the BR
right back and Spencer Martin moves right across
the blue paint and makes another Sensational stop
yeah right now he is is so locked in in this game
and he's made some massive saves to keep it at
zero for the Blue Jackets coing send it back in
Fr oh want to stop by for Rebound another chance
in front that's knocked out by Cher to punch
that away Pino a great chance at the side of
the net and Jacob Cher might have just saved the
goal skates into the Zone off the stick and T was
on his way to the bench heer's moving and wrapped
with the diving play he lost the stick to stop E's
mile I wow what a PO things got real interesting
there they sure did BR to start to leave the N oh
no here comes nickers but Rand does a great job
diving back gets a stick on it gel he's got two
on the game for the hatri across L Tang to save
ERS the one timer on the feed from gensel and
terrific right toe save there by Arison play down
for hegy cross the ice to Chuck tapped off the p
and then sokin made a save on Rodriguez a wide
open net for Evan Rodriguez first one found iron
sokin got the second skars it right into the
post and then on the follow through with the
backand sokin got a glove on [Music] it three of
them over the line but M it's champ Bon toes save
by gson what an opportunity to tie the game and
gustofson forced to make his biggest stop of the
first period now watch this little play gets it to
lyol right back to M japani what a great stretch
Gun Works in and a spraing mar tried to block
Everly took it right away Everly stop what to
save my wall wall reads it and gets over there
every can't Elevate great save oh man Joseph
wall kessing will take it away to the front
oh and he can't kill her can't finish it off
jur just gets his knob of a stick on that one
otherwise Keller tucks that one in Short side
kzo from the corner slides it across van to
save Miller knocks it off the line kzo shoot
pitch blocked by heer what a save by heer yes
vanich first then Colin Miller then Nico heer
a team effort on this penalty kill look at
that save by vanich and then another right
pad save as he's down and Niko heser with the
net open comes across gets the body in the way
what a sequence for vanich and the rest of the
Devils penalty killers and a huge stop trying
to play that one below the goal line comes back
to the point rebound oh what a save by lucing it
again he has done it again another highlight
reel save and look at how the splits right
there and then he goes right from the splits
gets that glove though and just continues to
battle radish to the goal to Bard the shot oh look
at that lion what a stop from Bard big save Lion
on Conor Bard into the slot one time ainson stop
rebound oh n delovic you have got to be kidding
me full extension in the robbery Alex NAD delovic
highlight re stop wow this guy are you kidding me
right now delovic had to come up with a big time
save there he was in front sa rebound oh diam
stop my heart spectacular Carter har you got to
be kidding me that is too just ridiculous Saves
by heart two in a row rebound loose there diving
keer got a cross on Maro to keep it a three love
deficit that's the save of the game for Darcy
that's a great acrobatic move Mar so Anderson oh
that one was redirected off the back wall oh what
a sensational save reaching out with a glove is
Elvis M leans and that as fine a save as you will
see shot pass go it bear is it in or not they say
no it looked like it was over the line from Comer
but right there it is waved off no goal wow what
an opportunity there good save from comry to keep
that out of the net back across chance save uner
he came out quickly challenged Stam coast and
sent it up and out of play G gando wowza here's
a chance for sta wi goes on goal what a save
reaching back back by dord as it went off the
defender and on net but it goes off of the stick
and forces dord to go back to the glove side fou
to the net and a big p save Gibson it's underneath
him and somehow wood did not score that's a great
stop great stop by John Gibson and John Gibson
just manages to get that right tow out at the
last second to deny Colton close around the net
stopped in front back cander save oh quick with a
great save diving spraing save by Jonathan Qui
absolutely fabulous save what flexibility for
a 37y old golender to look out caught her wide
open and a save by Bennington what a glove save
there on cter what a save by Jordan Bennington
here there's a shot and a stretching save by
lanin and the follow-up stopped as well look at
lanin whole Nets open gets over look at the glove
and just reaches back in desperation that's an
unbelievable save that's a game saer right there
he's had a couple in this period knocked off his
dick done follows up for the Sho the save oh and a
great save on the rebound by monbo kicking out the
pad off lenberg that's the second time he's burnt
wber